okay after this totally abortive attempt
at outreach by Donald Trump to black
voters where he basically said hey
you're all poor none of you are working
you all have crappy schools right that
was Trump attempting to reach out to
black people after that the surrogates
the advisers the supporters they start
popping up on news media trying to
defend what he said now sometimes merely
needing an explainer is bad like for
example remember last week maybe the
week before when Donald Trump sort of
implied hey maybe my supporters could
kill Hillary Clinton if she's elected
and then all the surrogates show up
Louis and they starting oh no what he
was trying to do is mobilize the second
amendment vote really then why did he
say if Hillary wins right because if
you're trying to mobilize the vote you
don't give suggestions for what should
happen after the vote is done okay
anyway just having people explaining
away an implicit suggestion that people
should kill your opponent that's a loss
to begin with so on CNN Brianna Keilar
is interviewed by former Georgia
Republican congressman Jack Kingston who
is uh totally cuckoo for cocoa puffs
okay we're talking about is that it's
bad and he shows up and he was asked by
Brianna Keilar a very sensible question
which is you know Trump goes to these
white cities right 96.4 percent white
dimondale michigan and he makes a
bizarre appeal to black people is this
is this the best thing to do listen to
how kingston responds to this it is
utter insanity well proposal II saying
you know what I'm interested I went till
Milwaukee I'm here tonight I want to
talk to you one of the things he
actually said last night in North
Carolina they kind of went uncovered but
he says I don't want to preside over
another generation of children too much
because you see he's going there but
he's not he's in dimondale which is
ninety-three percent white when he was
in Milwaukee the other day it was a part
of milwaukee that was dealing i mean he
it's yeah but Briana table
lately why I I mean it maybe it would
have been nice if he went had a backdrop
with a burning car but the real no no no
look just to be I'm not talking about a
burn are talking about meeting with
voters well he met with David Clarke who
as you know the african-american sheriff
rile walking and he's engaged with them
in his rig we have to just call this as
completely racial racist or racial list
pandering to white voters who maintain
this caricature that I guess what what
what is being implied here that the sort
of natural scenario that we should be
used to seeing black people relate to is
cars burning in sort of this imagery of
riotous looting and and and insanity I
mean that we the right is going crazy
saying if you see racism in what
Kingston said you're the racist know
sometimes pointing out that someone else
is appealing to racist stereotypes is
not racist and this is one of those
cases yeah the burning car right now is
the Donald Trump and uh this sounds like
the type of rhetoric that Donald Trump
would use earlier in his campaign yeah
just to to kind of a rally white
supremacist and racists and and people
with general xenophobic attitudes when I
see this jason I actually start thinking
you know if Trump were really trying to
lose the campaign you'd go out and make
a crazy appeal to black people and then
to fix it you'd send out this guy and
you would have him reference black
people feeling at home in scenarios
where cars are burning in the background
this is what you would be doing if you
were trying to throw the election isn't
it pretty much i'm pretty sure the only
only thing he knows about black people
is like the los angeles riots and the
busy scene at them and that's you know
where he's gonna go with with all this
well he has great relationship with the
blacks louis he's gonna win the blacks
is gonna do terrific because he's gonna
heat the the blacks and Trump are gonna
win again after he goes out there and of
course trust me trust me on this which
is his new favorite line where when you
have no data to back up what you're
saying you just say trust me Mexico's
gonna build the wall trust me on that
ladies and gentlemen believe you me and
said that there's nothing to this no I
don't see how he's going to uh to get
any black people to go for but let's not
forget he does have one black friend
which he referred to as my
african-american here is our one rally
he's got that guy's vote presumably I I
was sometimes when I see something like
this I try to say okay what's an
explanation for how this transpired my
explanation is former congressman
Kingston thought they were in a
commercial break and do you realize that
there that this was live television with
his comments were going out to air
that's the only way I could rationalize
this happening or he thought he was on
SNL right yeah that's the other
possibility I've talked about how people
of all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is zip car
which gets you a car when you want it
when you need it they offer all sorts of
cars SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com slash david